avec nous au plateau Carimi ah oui Karim
bonjour vous revenez donc d'une mission
de 2 semaines pour France 24 dans le
don-basse d'abord arrêtons-nous sur la
situation à parthout la bataille a
commencé l'été dernier pourquoi est-elle
si longue elle est extrêmement longue
parce que il y a une résistance
s'acharnée des
Ukrainiens on a vu des vagues d'hommes
tentés de submerger l'armée ukrainienne
des hommes souvent mal entraînés des
hommes qu'on est parfois allé chercher
en prison pour alimenter les troupes de
Wagner et du côté ukrainien on était
clairement mieux préparé mais ce qu'on a
rencontré nous offrons nous ont fait
part de leur incompréhension pourquoi
s'acharner avec une telle vigueur sur
barmouth qui n'est pas une ville
stratégique certes l'axe darkmouth la
viande et stratégique pour les Russes
mais pas la ville en elle-même
évidemment on l'a répété à maintes
reprises c'est devenu une ville
hautement symbolique pour pour les
Russes qui veulent la prendre pour en
quelque sorte marquer les esprits on
sait du côté de Prigogine l'influent
patron de Wagner c'était même un cadeau
qu'il espérait faire pour le 24 février
à Vladimir Poutine ces derniers temps il
a expliqué que la prise de Barco n'était
pas encore acquise mais là on voit que
les difficultés sont de plus en plus
importantes pour les ukrainiens et ce
n'est pas un hasard si le commandant en
chef des troupes
ukrainiennes à leur a rendu visite pour
tenter de rebooster leur moral parce que
c'est vague humaine ont continué sans
discontinuer même si ces derniers temps
ça a un petit peu évolué à combattant
sur place expliqué que ils avaient
affaire à des groupes de 50 hommes qui
venaient en quelque sorte s'empaler sur
les défenses ukrainiennes désormais
c'est plutôt des des groupes d'une
dizaine d'hommes qui semblent plus
aguerris et qui c'est important de le
souligner lorsqu'il y a des blessés ou
des morts à l'intérieur de ces petites
unités et bien il le recul pour les
évacuer donc ce n'est plus forcément les
mêmes hommes auxquels ils ont eu affaire
dans un premier temps en tout cas la
situation est très difficile le
président ukrainien la souligné mais en
même temps pour pour les Ukrainiens
c'est cette bataille signifie aussi
énormément de pertes infligées aux
Russes à un moment on était autour de
800 900 hommes tués par les Ukrainiens
des hommes donc appartenant aux troupes
russes et donc sans doute que on tente
de faire un maximum de dégâts à l'ennemi
avant peut-être de d'abandonner la ville
plus largement dans le don basque et la
situation est-ce que les lignes de front
évoluent elles évoluent assez peu et ce
qui se passe du côté de de bar mout on
le retrouve un peu ailleurs avec on
parle beaucoup des hommes et des combats
quasiment au corps à corps dans le
centre de barmouth mais ces hommes ont
besoin d'être soutenus notamment par des
temps qui est par de l'artillerie et
c'est là que les difficultés sont
importantes pour les Ukrainiens puisque
leurs moyens sont extrêmement limités
les des armes modernes en provenance de
l'Occident ne sont pas encore arrivés et
le problème aussi c'est que si on
utilise des armes de l'époque soviétique
parfois des années 50 ou 60 comme dans
une vieille unité où nous nous sommes
rendus même pour ces armes ils ont des
difficultés d'approvisionnement pour les
munitions
un soldat sur le front nous confier que
une grande partie des tirs échoués à
cause de la mauvaise qualité des
munitions parfois de fabrication
pakistanaise des répliques de munitions
russes qui datent quasiment d'après la
deuxième guerre mondiale et donc cette
artillerie c'est ce qui permet de
protéger les troupes qui sont un peu
plus en avant et qui sont quasiment au
contact direct avec les Russes et si on
ne peut pas les protéger elles sont
obligées de reculer et c'est un petit
peu ce qui se passe à barmouth mais
aussi du côté de donetskou on a juste
pour l'instant la capacité de résister
et pas du tout de contre-attaquer Karim
vous êtes rendu également avec le reste
de l'équipe un Catherine noristrehant et
Moha
c'est plus dans le sud ville libérée par
les Ukrainiens mais toujours visé par
les Russes toujours visé c'est une ville
qui est toujours en guerre alors le
blast de halson et bien les Russes ils
sont restés pendant plusieurs mois ils
ont reculé en détruisant la plupart des
infrastructures des écoles des hôpitaux
les populations sont assez traumatisées
on parle énormément de cette capacité de
résilience de résistance médias tout de
même beaucoup d'usure chez les gens
qu'on a rencontré dans cette région de
Herson et puis la ville même de Herson
et bombarder quotidiennement 85% de la
population a préféré partir il reste des
personnes qui qui ont le sentiment que
si elles partent elles vont tout perdre
parce qu'elles ont peu une petite
appartement une petite maison ou alors
qu'elles n'ont nulle part où aller mais
en tout cas cette victoire extrêmement
symbolique pour les Ukrainiens il la
paye cher aujourd'hui puisque la vie à
halson est tout simplement impossible
merci beaucoup Karim et oui et chapeau
pour